the right-hander chris archer making his
return to the raise
a few seasons away in pittsburgh
did not pitch in 2020 had surgery for
thoracic
outlet syndrome did not start in his
first outing came in relief it was a
piggyback
start rich hill got the start chris
archer came in relief that was his line
but today is his day here is dj
la mayhew to lead it off check swing the
appeal straight three
marty foster at first ring some dj lemay
hugh and archer
in his first batter back to tropicana
field has struck him out you know he's
missed two games everybody's getting a
little bit nervous general soreness but
aaron judge is back in the lineup
and that is a big thing for the yankees
swung on and missed strike three
and look at that i mean a slider that
ended up middle of the plate and judge
swung right through it for out number
two domingo herman finishing up his
warm-up tosses only one start
didn't go great only three innings
here's austin meadows
he's seven for 26 two homers two rbis
that's a shot toward the corner that's
got some carry might go
that's out of here home run for austin
meadows
a 2-1 pitch and meadows lines it out of
here
to give the rage a one-nothing lead just
above the 322 sign and just
clanked off of the meshing of that foul
pole
third home run of the year for austin
meadows and that continues a trend
for domingo vermont he has now allowed
at least one homer in each of his last
12 starts second and third corners
coming in
at francisco mejia who's had a hit in
all three of his prior games switcher
batting left
ground ball off of hermon and it
trickles out towards right field
a late great file of ahu wendell scores
adamus scores
it's a two-run infield single and the
rays have a three-nothing lead
it was a ground ball that ricocheted to
the open area between first and second
and tampa scores two runs both runners
scored it's now a three nothing game
camera
and with one away here is le mayhew that
one is ripped to left field it's a base
hit
and over the head of meadows backing up
is phillips
and lemay will get to second we've got a
little issue on the mound apparently
with
uh archer mejia went out there to
check on him and made a move the motion
toward the dugout kevin cash out and
that's going to be it for archer
you have to wonder what else could go
wrong physically when it comes to the
health of the pitching staff the rose
arena won for five yesterday
but a single and a run bedded in a
stolen base still the only stolen base
of the year for the race
here's a swing at a drive by a rose
arena to center field hicks going back
turns around it is gone
randy arose arena for the first time in
2021
it's a homer to straight away center
field and the raised lead is now
four nothing well this raised lineup
they have gone after her
he has been out over the plate ready to
hit early in counts
and uh you think he knew it and if
you're gonna do that on a drive to
center field it's a
pretty legit home run to center field in
this place
you've got to get all of it phillips a
left hand hitter
phillips crowded to first his first time
skyed into left center field going on
the run is
gardner and he makes the play
took an extra base in away from phillips
who salutes him
on a job well done and brett gardner's
making the claim for some playing time
we're just not going to see a better
catch than that
and phillips has to salute him give him
credit for that but boy
what a grab i i mean a perfect route
justin wilson in his second tour duty
with the yankees last year with the mets
good numbers 23 strikeouts
rounded the third diving stop michelle
from his fanny throws to first in time
what a play don't forget a left hand
hitters up so he's the only one on the
left side
he sprawled to get the ground ball and
from his backside
he threw to first perfectly now joey
wendell who's hitting everything hard
his first game and a half on the
homestead
oh look out window grazed by that pitch
always scary up there yeah and you
wonder between these two teams if uh
if there's anything going to come out of
this chat when uh
yeah because you you i mean you remember
when he almost got his
head taken off by a hundred mile an hour
fastball
over his head on purpose because
the rays and yankees have had this going
on the last few seasons
and then in the playoffs bottom of the
eighth the revenge
the blast zoo with two outs the walk of
the double having to raise an
opportunity to tack on
swinging a ground ball right side le
mayhew on the second half has it throws
to first and raise
leave a little more chicken on the bone
one out one on and here's aaron hicks
hicks
a single walk today he's also struck out
swinging a chopper back up toward the
middle now waits at second for it
gets the out there throw to first it's
in time for the double play
nice play by brandon lau he showed
patience waiting for that ball to come
over to him at second base he held on to
the bag got the force there and then the
throw to first
out away from shutting out new york
high fly ball center field phillips is
there
ray's winning a one two three ninth
prevention
accommodation shutout for the raids
four nothing but final